.
IF THEY HAVE THE EVIDENCE, THEY
WILL BRING THE CHARGES AND
PROSECUTE APPROPRIATELY.
AND I SUPPORT THEM IN THAT.
>> SENATOR, LET'S TURN TO
PRESIDENT BIDEN'S DECISION TO
CANCEL BILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN
STUDENT LOANS.
YOU'VE BEEN PUSHING FOR THIS FOR
A LONG TIME.
IT WAS A KEY PART OF YOUR
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
AND YET THIS DEBT RELIEF IS NOT
AS MUCH AS YOU WANTED.
ARE YOU DISAPPOINTED THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN DIDN'T GO
FURTHER?
>> I AM SO HAPPY TO SEE WHAT HAS
HAPPENED.
I RECOGNIZE THAT RIGHT NOW HARD
WORKING FAMILIES, MIDDLE CLASS
FAMILIES, WORKING CLASS
FAMILIES, HAVE GOTTEN SOME REAL
RELIEF.
THINK ABOUT IT THIS WAY.
MOST OF THE RELIEF THAT THE
PRESIDENT HAS GIVEN -- REMEMBER,
THE MAJORITY OF PEOPLE WILL GET
$20,000 IN STUDENT LOAN DEBT
RELIEF.
40% OF THE FOLKS WHO HAVE
STUDENT LOANS DO NOT HAVE A
COLLEGE DIPLOMA, A FOUR-YEAR
DIPLOMA.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRUCK
DRIVERS AND WHO ARE NAIL
TECHNICIANS AND NURSES' AIDES.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY GOING TO GET
THEIR DEBT CANCELED OUT.
AND THAT MEANS THEY'RE GOING TO
BE ABLE TO BUILD STRONGER
FUTURES FOR THEMSELVES AND FOR
THEIR CHILDREN.
THIS IS ABOUT AMERICA INVESTING
IN PEOPLE WHO WORK HARD, WHO
PLAY BY THE RULES, AND WHO JUST
NEED A GOVERNMENT ON THEIR SIDE.
AND JOE BIDEN HAS DONE WHAT JOE
BIDEN DOES BEST.
HE HAS DELIVERED FOR WORKING
FAMILIES.
>> ON THAT NOTE, SENATOR, I WANT
YOU TO LISTEN TO ONE RAENGZ FROM
A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER WHO
THINKS HE HAS PLAYED BY THE
RULES.
HIS NAME IS BRIAN LONSBERRY.
>> WE HAVE DONE THE SACRIFICES,
THE NO VACATIONS, NO OUT TO
EATS.
AND NOW I'M ON THE OTHER SIDE.
THE REASON IT UPSETS ME SO MUCH
IS ARE WE SETTING A GOOD
EXAMPLE?
IT'S A LITTLE UPSETTING WE KEPT
PAYING AND STRUGGLING AND OTHER
PEOPLE GAVE UP AND QUIT.
AND I WASN'T RAISED TO QUIT.
>> WHAT DO YOU SAY TO BRIAN AND
OTHERS WHO SAY THIS IS REALLY
NOT FAIR THAT STUDENT LOAN IS
JUST ONE KIND OF DEBT AND THERE
ARE OTHER PEOPLE WHO DON'T HAVE
THAT BUT HAVE OTHER STRUGGLES
THE GOVERNMENT ISN'T HELPING
THEM WITH?
>> I THINK A LOT ABOUT FAIRNESS.
AND I THINK ABOUT HOW EDUCATION
DEBT IS DIFFERENT FROM OTHER
DEBT.
I LOOK AT IT THIS WAY.
I WANTED TO BE A PUBLIC SCHOOL
TEACHER FROM THE TIME I WAS IN
SECOND GRADE.
MY DADDY ENDED UP AS JANITOR.
THERE WAS NO MONEY FOR ME TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
BUT I FOUND A PUBLIC UNIVERSITY
THAT COST $50 A SEMESTER.
AND FOR A PRICE I COULD PAY FOR
ON A PART-TIME WAITRESSING JOB,
I FINISHED A FOUR-YEAR DIPLOMA.
I BECAME A SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHER AND IT OPENED A MILLION
DOORS FOR ME.
THAT OPPORTUNITY IS NOT OUT
THERE TODAY FOR ANY OF OUR KIDS.
OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM IS
NO LONGER CREATING OPPORTUNITIES
FOR KIDS LIKE ME AND OTHER KIDS
WHOSE FAMILIES CAN'T AFFORD TO
WRITE A CHECK.
INSTEAD, WE'RE SAYING TO THESE
YOUNG PEOPLE, YOU'VE GOT TO GET
AN EDUCATION, BUT WE ARE GOING
TO WRAP THE CHAINS OF DEBT
AROUND YOU.
FOR ME, YOU'RE GOING TO BE
PAYING IT FOR DECADES INTO THE
FUTURE.
INCLUDING GETTING SOCIAL
SECURITY CHECKS GARNISHED.
THAT'S NOT THE AMERICA WE WANT.
>> I'M NOT SURE --
>> WE WANT TO BE AN AMERICA OF
OPPORTUNITY.
>> I'M NOT SURE THIS RELIEVING
THIS AMOUNT OF DEBT CHANGES THE
COST OF COLLEGE.
THE COST OF COLLEGE IS STILL
EXORBITANT.
>> LOOK.
PART OF WHAT IT DOES, IT DEALS
WITH THE DEBT THAT HAS BEEN
BUILT UP BECAUSE THE COST OF
COLLEGE HAS GONE UP, BECAUSE
TAXPAYERS HAVE MADE FEWER
INVESTMENTS IN OUR PUBLIC
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES
BECAUSE FOR-PROFIT COLLEGES HAVE
SWOOPED IN AND FIGURED OUT THAT
THEY CAN CHEAT A LOT O